could libya return to civil war once
again two rival prime ministers are
jostling for power triggering fighting
in the capital tripoli elections are
delayed and peace talks have made little
progress so what's next this is inside
story
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm hashem
people in libya are voicing fears of a
return to civil war two rival
governments signed a ceasefire last year
to end years of fighting
following the fall of long-time leader
muhammad gaddafi in 2011.
they were supposed to work together and
hold elections but that hasn't happened
on tuesday the prime minister of the
administration in tobruk tried to
install himself in the capital tripoli
that triggered street battles which
killed at least one person and wounded
five laura berdimalli reports
a takeover attempt at the crack of dawn
the prime minister of the rival
parliament in the eastern city of tabruk
tried to enter libya's capital on
tuesday morning
but militia's loyal to the unrecognized
government in tripoli opened fire on his
convoy
hours of street battles forced fatih
bashar and his ministers to retreat
he's moving his government for now to
cert a city halfway between tripoli and
tabruk
bashar says he doesn't regret the
takeover attempt saying leaders in
tripoli are refusing
that government has worked to delay and
undermine the election they refused to
go to the election approved by the
international community and the un we
did not resort to force or insults we
followed a political process
his rival abdul hamid daba accused
bashar of an attempted coup
libyan
the eyes of the libyans that i saw today
combined fear and panic but there was
hope and challenge in them
the fear is to go back to the past to
war to violence to chaos to destruction
and to smoke
libya has been split between rival
powers in the east and west since
long-time leader muammar gaddafi was
overthrown and killed 11 years ago
after years of fighting un peace talks
led to a ceasefire in march of last year
the opposing sides came together and
chose the baba as the head of the
national unity government
but splits re-emerged in december when
elections were postponed because of
disagreements on candidates and how to
hold the vote
two months later the tobruk-based
parliament chose fatih bashara as prime
minister
many libyans say they want the divisions
to end
us in a very odd situation the only
solution for this conflict is holding
elections
those who are fighting for power can go
fight in the desert and we will welcome
whoever comes back victorious
france has urged all sides to respect
the ceasefire
but until the rival administrations
agree on a path forward many libyans
fear more violence to come
more about manly for inside story
let's bring in our guests in tripoli
salah
political analyst iran sylvia clumber
associate fellow in the mediterranean
middle east and africa program at the
institute of international affairs in
paris mustafa fituri journalist and
political commentator welcome to the
program
uh salah
let's try to understand exactly what
happened in tripoli so this is
the prime minister that was appointed by
the tripoli by the toborok
a part-based parliament father bashar on
his way to the capital to take over
from the
triply backed abdul hamid at the bible
and suddenly street battles
erupted who is to blame here
well uh
bashara
uh tried several times to install
himself in tripoli and failed and this
time he tried to enter tripoli uh three
o'clock in the morning uh
went to a house belonging to a
militar uh an armed group in tripoli
and uh he was uh cornered there
uh at five o'clock uh in the morning
negotiations
started
with baba government that granted
bashara and his
minister of health
a safe passage out of the city at about
7 30 in the morning
forces the loyal to the unity government
accompanied bashara all the way to about
400 kilometers south of tripoli to the
town of shwerev where he was handed over
to target busied uh
military uh unit that uh belongs to
after and the thing uh ended right there
and then after some clashes and the uh
like your report uh suggested uh the
killing of one uh person
sylvia this does not really seem like a
an isolated incident this looks like uh
a deeper political divide that has never
been solved
yes indeed i mean we have seen uh over
the past uh
nine months or so actually a growth in
tensions political tensions within
libya after the first initial months of
the government of
abdullah del beba
in 2021 and
it's part of a general
attempt by political forces in libya to
keep the conflict frozen
um
in order to continue to benefit from the
chaos and from the situation of
uncertainty
and this has for example been played out
quite meaningfully in the way in which
in late 2021
the need to undertake elections was
confronted with uh discussions about the
need to start from revising the
constitution and how the constitution
should take precedence over the
elections and i mean all these
discussions and the locate the blocks
that have been put to the electoral road
map uh have been just a way to boycott
and delay
a process that was very fragile from the
very beginning but that could have in
the end uh brought libya uh to the next
stage now we are kind of frozen in the
situation of being really at the
beginning of uh
of a transition and a lot of uncertainty
exists and a lot of efforts that have
been made in the past
um basically one year and a half since
the ceasefire was reached in late
october 2020 have been wasted okay
mustafa so
in
2021 the united nations uh
led a political process to put an end to
the instability in the country that
process paved the way for abdul hamid
to take over
as
prime minister then
in in february this year the parliament
in tobruk decides to appoint father
bashar
as prime minister was this a legal
from a legal perspective was it a
legitimate decision by the turbo based
parliament
well thank you asim for having me i i
think if you if you consider the
parliament that gave dwemer uh
the vote of confidence last march
uh and in march uh
last year
after he was elected by the libyan
political
dialogue form
in tunisia as you mentioned
if you consider that parliament to be
legally elected and legally empowered
and its mandate has not expired which
which is of course not true
then you have to accept that it's the
same parliament that came back and voted
mr bashar in and we have to remember
something very important here
the fact that uh the same parliament uh
stripped mr uh baby the vote of
confidence
last september so he became literally
legally speaking
a caretaker prime minister until
elections which was planned for december
but that that did not happen so the
legality issue here actually touches
everybody you know whether you say
if the parliament is not legal
then it's not legal in the first place
across the board that means bringing in
uh giving at babe a vote of confidence
as i mentioned then it's
illegal as well okay you can't really
you can't really say what's uh well it's
a democratic legal process when you get
the vote of confidence and then when you
lose that and uh being replaced you say
well that's a fraud that's a legal death
um
you understand why i i ask you that
question about about the parliament
because you have three institutions here
you have the parliament into broke you
have the
unity government based in tripoli and
you have the
the state council and the three
institutions creating loads of problems
for the international community and
people trying to understand what is
happening in libya for this is why i'm
going now to salah this is what is
happening as we speak
the the based parliament is saying
father bashar has to take over father
bashar has to oversee the drafting of a
constitution that would be conducive to
new elections that would usher in a new
era in libya
people in tripoli are saying no
happy that the baby is not going to hand
over power
until the elections are held until there
is a new legislature put into place so
we have we have two different narratives
here we have two different world views
here
look look what what mr ferturi said is
not
very precise
okay
the parliament gave
that baba government
the vote of confidence but mr fatoris
told you correctly
that the government was not chosen
by
the parliament was chosen by the libyan
political
dialogue forum in geneva
so okay you can you can
take back the vote of confidence which
you gave the government by
by acclimation
but you can't install a new government
that's the business of the lpdf which
installed at baba
the parliament did not choose it baber
the parliament as a matter of fact mr
bashara and mr aguilar the the hor
president were on the opposing ticket to
mr ed babe
and mr uh niffy
and they lost in geneva and that's why
baba came into power secondly
secondly the article three of the
roadmap states
that the the the uh
that the mandate of the government
extends 18 months
provided that elections are held on the
24th of december 2021.
which doesn't happen that's why baby
which did not happen so that's why baby
is saying
uh with some uh i guess justification
that he will he will hand over power to
an elected government
the thing is the the thing with that we
have to understand is that neither babe
nor bashar are the important thing here
the important thing is that we need
elections so we can get rid of
uh
the the high council of state and the
parliament which have been in power for
10 years and jointly are responsible for
10 transitional governments okay
keeping baby keeping it baby is the only
leverage we have to force these two
bodies to give up power and
set elections that 2.8 million people
demand by registering for the elections
sylvia it seems that there is
there's absolutely no way to have
elections in libya and unless you bridge
the divide between the east and the west
which has been the main reason why we're
having these problems and for this i
would like to ask you
do you think that this is the ultimate
problem of the international community
of the u.n in particular which has
failed to deliver on the promise to
unify the libyans
well there are a few points here we know
by the experience of other countries
that elections are ultimately and
by nature
divisive so in a country such as libya
uh it's very difficult to use elections
as a peace building tool
and this is not gonna this is not going
to work but at the same time as this
previous speaker has outlined quite
correctly we can't uh um we can't attain
to a new stage we can't overcome the
current deadlock if
we don't move to new legitimacy new
legitimate authorities that can really
uh address libya's problems and libya's
problems are
not the institutional problems there are
other issues the security issue of
course but also economic issues that
people care much more about and what in
terms of a second point about the
international community i mean i think
the failure of the
u.n
i mean is due to many many factors of
course and partly this is also due to
the fact that the u.n um
i mean the road map and the way it has
been managed has depleted the legitimacy
of this institution in the eyes of the
libyan people we know that there is also
a looming deadline for the mandate of
the u.n mission libya at the end of july
this year which is quite important to to
recall and so we don't know exactly what
will happen and uh just now um western
uh external
players are starting to realize that if
the this mandate is not renewed i mean
really we will lose uh the external uh
international community will lose in
terms of
being able to to influence or to to
support the libyan transition whatever
form it takes but it's also true that in
this past 12 years it hasn't been
very successful because of many uh
resistance from the libyan people
themselves to vis-a-vis the iran system
mustafa the the the
the tripoli-based
national unity government
has always been skeptical of any attempt
by the trobuk-based parliament to move
forward they say they are being
manipulated by the most powerful man in
the east uh
khalifa hafta to orchestrate a coup to
undermine
the people in the in the west what do
you think would be the next reaction for
khalifa
against the backdrop of this political
deadlock
well i i don't really expect much from
and
politically speaking from mr haftar at
the moment
i think everybody is likely to wait
for their firm position if you like
until after
mid-june or 23rd of june
as the road map
brokered by
stephanie williams last year
come to an end which means that the
government of mr baber will also come to
an end and that's that's the big problem
that's the big question mark because
what will happen then
i think basically what has been
happening in libya since 2011 since the
foreign military intervention
the lack of contingency plans if you
like or blend a
and the plan b which means by which i
mean if your plan a fails do you have a
plan b and how to implement that plan
that has not happened in 2011 because
what happened then was
libyans were promised paradise you know
in their country of democracy and the
economic growth
once the gedavi and his government are
gone the following day they are gone and
libya ended up where it is today there
was no plan b the same thing happened
here
first problem with mr baber was the fact
that he bribed his way into
the the the boast of uh
uh prime minister without a proper
investigation from the united nations at
the time so that that was in november i
mean
in tunisia during the uh the uh the last
session of the libyan political dialogue
in tunisia before they moved to geneva
the when you look at the situation now
libya
when when the divide was going on
it created some sort of regional
realignment
egypt the uae and russia they were
providing support for the
east qatar turkey were providing support
for the
west is it is is the image
is the political landscape still the
same
uh definitely uh uh as far as as uh the
emirates is concerned is no longer
providing the uh support it was
providing after before uh it has been uh
reduced tremendously if not uh stopped
altogether uh it found i guess in the
baby a known quantity the imarat has
known baba since uh he was a high
government official in the qadhafi
regime
and they seem to be comfortable with the
with them
and they are in constant communications
the egyptians don't want elections
because elections mean definitely
that aguero salah is not going to be
back as head of the parliament and
hafter
will will be under great pressure
because he's always claimed he has
always claimed that he will only submit
to an elected
government in libya and they know that a
a new elected government in libya may
not guarantee the survival of after so
the egyptians are adamant about opposing
elections and supporting aguila salah
and after also noticed that
haftar and aguila they were the ones who
opposed the government of uh
of uh the gn the gna the government of
national accord of mr saraj
since its beginning and that government
was born out of the rat agreement
between
the parliament and the
gnc at that time
after again after agreement between the
the the parliament and the uh uh how the
high council of state and other uh
parties in geneva
uh declared three months after the after
the government got its uh mandate from
the parliament that he does not
recognize this government and banned mr
baba from entering the east or the south
let me go to that's why uh
so that's why stephanie williams in her
opening speech in cairo said we tried
everything we tried transitional
government we tried power sharing
agreements we have to go to elections
because all other solutions and she also
said we need consensus sylvia do you
think that with the cairo talks
that could be an opportunity to
reconcile some of the differences
between the key architects particularly
the turks the egyptians the emiratis the
qataris about how to move forward
well uh the cairo talks have been uh uh
crafted in a way to kind of go uh in
parallel to the the process that started
in berlin
in uh january 2020 and there was at the
berlin two conference one year ago um
and i don't see why the the characters
should
succeed in bringing you know the
original players or the backers of the
different factions in libya to
i mean common terms
and
particularly because as it was said the
cairo doesn't have any interest in
leveling the playing field and allowing
libyans to choose freely
who is going to basically
rule them so i don't really trust
this process to have any meaningful
results it is a good
opportunity for the time being to keep
the channels of communication open but i
don't think it's gonna solve the major
problems and uh this is an example of
the fact that the regional players are
back in uh in the field in controlling
the process because the international
community and they are in particular
has kind of lost control of the
situation mustafa this must be a very
delicate moment for the libyan people
there
they're looking at the situation the
politicians are jostling for power and
bigger say and at the same time the
they're concerned that this could be
conducive to civil war once again in the
country
well however unlikely the possibility of
another civil war is always there and
libya's always a bigger kind and present
risk and we have to remember that
the risk has increased since
the
the representative of mr after on the
five plus five military commission which
brought in the cease-fire in 2020
uh has already suspended
its participation the whole group five
of them and they not just that they
recommended to mr hafter to suspend
consider the ceasefire
suspended and
even asked them to take certain measures
to make sure that it is
not in place anymore and of course they
as usual they accused the other side the
government jnu uh and in tripoli uh
violating the terms of the ceasefire and
they they are partly right in this
accusation because mr babe when bashar
was voted in
last february uh took certain measures
that really violated the ceasefire
but but but
not in terms of i say
violence erupting again
yes
thank you thank you very much indeed
mustafa ferturi sylvia colombo salah
bakusha really appreciate your insight
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com for
further discussion go to our facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
aj inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from hashimoto and the
entire team here in doha bye for now
[Music]